- [Woman] Hi!
- [Man] Hey, nice to meet you.
- In the flesh.
- All right. Ciara Reynolds.
- Ben!
- Who are you? I know nothing.
Ciara...
Reynolds...
(orchestral music)
All right. Yeah.
I can be into this.
Tampa...
- I'm from Tampa.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I love Tampa.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- They have that pirate
festival every year.
It started in May 1904,
then the first sea-based
invasion happened in like 1911.
- Wow, how do you...
that's really specific.
- I don't know. Big fan.
What's your favorite kind of music?
- Indie. You?
- Indie.
- Favorite band?
- Favorite band...
Auri and the Squid...
Auri and the Squid.
- How do you know Auri and the Squid?
- You do not know Auri and the Squid.
- I love Auri and the Squid.
- [Man] Get out of here! No!
Favorite song on three.
- [Woman] One, two, three!
- [Man] One, two, three!
- [Woman] Island Romance!
- [Man] Island Romance!
- Oh my God!
- Wait, is this...
- How, how.
- Yeah.
- Who is this guy, Brad...
Take every picture together.
We got the ex.
Yeah, I don't know,
I just got out of a pretty
serious relationship.
What about you?
- Nothing since college, actually.
- Not even a little thing, anything.
- No, I'm like, I work, I have cats.
- This is like, multi-year
relationship here.
When did they break up?
- You really haven't dated anyone?
- No, no one.
- You're here now, right.
- Yeah, it's great.
- Being real, honest. Love it.
This dates back like five years.
Twitter, Facebook,
Instagram. What is this?
What am I doing?
Brad...
This kind of weird?
Nah.
I wonder if she still has a Myspace.
Where is it?
The answer, it's not
in here! It's nowhere!
Would you be able to
help me find someone's
Social Security number?
She's got a Brad tattoo, what?
- Okay, totally random question,
when I say the name
"Brad" what comes to mind?
- My brother's name is Brad.
- What do you mean?
- My brother, his name is Brad.
What do you mean?
- [Man] You mean your boyfriend.
- No, no, no, my brother's name is Brad.
We're, like, super
close, like best friends.
We live together.
(gagging)
- I got to go.
- Are you okay? Do you need a water?
(frantic breathing)
- Pick up, pick up, pick up.
Hey, hey, did you do it?
Call off the hit!
I can't kill him...
Oh my God, what have I done?
I'm so sorry about that.
- No, it's okay.
- That's never happened before.
- So, little bit of a confession...
I Googled you before this date.
And I thought you were
going to be an asshole,
and you're really a great guy.
- Yeah, me too.
- [ Man] Oh my God, I'm so happy.
Um...
You should give Brad
a call, though, right?
- I'm going to call him after.
- Maybe you should probably,
like, do it right now.
- Right now?
- Like, right now.
♫ My friends' been saying lately
♫ that I've been acting crazy
♫ because I'm so into you ♫